yes it would be wonderful if life were
like a musical and everything we said
was all in song
it would be so fabulous if we were in a
musical we could fall in love and make
romance
i just changed my mind about this little
musical i never want to see you drop
your pants
does anna kendrick
use auto-tune
how dare you
how very dare you that is rude no i
don't
have i had to do more than one take yes
have i used auto-tune get [ __ ]
you're so good in zombieland
not to make this weird but you're on my
boyfriend's list
how you doing
you doing good you haven't put a ring on
it yet what's going on
am i on your list
it's good to know i've got options thank
you he looks right at me and he goes
oh my gosh um he's talking about the
economy and jobs and stuff and he goes
oh my gosh actually anna was in one of
my favorite movies up in the air which
talked about the economy in the
recession and i was like oh this is such
an inconvenient time to be having a full
stroke which is obviously
what's happening
um and like you know these people are
like looking at me and so and then um we
get to shake his hand and take a photo
um so you know i shake his hand and he
says i hope i didn't embarrass you
earlier and i was like yeah you're such
an ass
i was checking into a hotel
and somebody came out and said oh do you
need help with your bags and
i thought they were doing a bit
so um i went oh i've been traveling all
day i have no idea
and then they
um kept talking like that
so i had to like slowly transition out
of it okay who's on your list then
um the top of my list is probably
huge oh that guy's an [ __ ]
[Applause]
this movie i can't even begin to tell
you how much i love this film it was uh
it's entertaining it's thought-provoking
it's a melancholy it's funny it's just a
really it's the total package go on
and you get to be with the pretty boy
george clooney yeah he's all right he
actually i sat him down
when we were shooting i sat him down and
tried to pick his brain about how to
give a really good interview and i swear
apropos of nothing he was like well if
you ever do letterman and in my mind i'm
like yeah okay george when i go on david
letterman but um but he was like uh he
was like just be really really nice and
if he gives you a hard time just keep
complimenting him so
um taylor swift or katy perry katy perry
i've heard that about you
it was a crazy night i've never been
around so many katy perry finger banged
my cleavage it was a weird night
she's very mature
this was an unplanned moment and i want
to stay right here
okay
i got my ticket for the long way round
two ball of whiskey for the way
and not sure like some sweet company and
i'm leaving tomorrow what do you say
when i'm gone
when i'm gone
you're gonna miss me when i'm gone
you're gonna miss me by my hair you're
gonna miss me everywhere oh you're sure
gonna miss me when i'm gone
what a chump
can you do maybe kristen stewart like
explaining what pitch perfect three is
about
um
um you know there's like the bellas are
out of college and um
you know
uh they go on a uso tour and there's
like
you know hilarity ensues so
oh my god
my dad sent me a box of cadbury eggs at
easter one year and it was just supposed
to be kind of a nice treat but i lived
off that bad boy for about a month
um but see this is this is good
experience i think i think for for
everybody to understand that life
doesn't come to you you have to go after
life
agreed well well put thank you very much
yeah sometimes you have to ride a dirt
bike into a christmas tree
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's this scene where like you kind
of just see like the half of a butt and
i was still like i don't want to show
half of my butt so i'll just you know
get about double because i'm a big timer
now and i'm allowed to do that
they bring you this folder of polaroids
of like naked women i felt so creepy i
felt like a serial killer we have you
instagrammed a picture of you with
beyonce and you did you you put this
heart around it no that was just there
oh no
and and i was like i think this this one
looks good and the producer was like her
butt's a little square and i was like do
i have a square butt
is that a thing that butts can be they
were like well all of these girls are
too tall and too tan so really it has to
be this one short pale girl so i was
like so i just saw all these naked women
for nothing i mean not for nothing it
was great but
which put me in the position of um
having to say the douchiest thing of all
time when somebody the douchiest i can't
wait to hear the douchiest thing of all
time get ready um
where somebody would be like oh you did
such a great job in your film
congratulations and i would have to say
which one
no matter how loud
no one can save
do you uh know what you want for
christmas
no not really um can i say though that
cat toy that that is that is a fur
covered dildo no
that's what that is
no no there was a factory
they were putting those out
they said they said
put a mit put a mitten on it and sell it
to children
no
well
just
it's for kids now whatever you want it
to be anna
can i have some cat toys please can we
[Applause]
wow you know
that never and i don't know what's the
matter with me but that never came to
mind
thank you very much brian
merry christmas
[Applause]
i've never met him and we talk on
twitter sometimes these long hashtags
about like you know improving yourself
and he's always hashtagging about like
team bring it because we're all on team
bring it and i once asked him in a
hashtag is there a height limit for team
bring it right and he never got back to
me so my feelings are a little hurt
right
[Music]
done
[Music]
and i can drink everybody
[Applause]